Mình xong tháng 8, lắm trọng tổ chức lễ từng viện tạm nằm buộc ném bong mươi từ đầu tiên trong việc sẽ nhé loại tạm thành phố Kilo Xima.
Thôi đơn xígu rùi xí ba đã thăm dựu bởi lễ.
Sự kiệt, lúc tạm dựng mấy lắm sáng, lắm nắm sảo tháng 8, nắm nửa trí chạm buộc nắm.
Mấy bây ném bong về 2 mi chính có bị ím măng tên nấu là gây đã thả có bong Ràn Yung nặng mời nghiênb Bông.
Cô bình dành lý tập vói xuống trụng tâm Kilo Xima.
Vụ nấu xảy ra các mà đất 5 trăm thăm emét, tạo ra nhìn lượng lên tới bụng nguyên đấu xây trong bản tình bụng phần nằm Kilo Mét,
khiến bệnh mệt tạm mi người chết mạng ngay lập tất.
Màng ngày sau và lúc môi mùi mùi mùi dơ sáng ngay mùi chi thở tâm.
Mì tế tục nè bong thứ 2, măng tên phết mèn chở lúc tổ niềm xuống nha gà xa gì bụng nổ đổ cao nông chơi mét, khiến 2 mi bài nghiênb rồi.
Chết ngay lại trổ.
Tếc đến năng hành cho 2 mi tơ, chính phụ nhật bản xác nhận tổng xuống nha thịt bản gió 2 bụng nè bong.
Là hơn nằm chăm của mi bản hình đôi.
2 bụng nổ này vẫn là những lần vuy nhất của khí hành nhân được xưa giống trong xung đồ trong lịch xử nhận loại.